hello my name is Jodie Whittaker and I'm
here with BuzzFeed talking about my
first times right let's go first
embarrassing moment on set what happens
is you get like a mark on the floor for
hitting your marks and things like that
and we had a long walking shop and it
was shot from behind and because the
first set was behind us I didn't realize
that the mic basically covers sound so
as the further aware we got the ladder I
got and heard you shout a mother that's
how I just making sure they can hear me
got a mic on I don't I had no idea I
thought the camera miles away had to
hear me so that was embarrassing first
celebrity crush
I've got asked this the other day Keanu
Reeves and it's still going on Point
Break days and now first embarrassing
audition story I mean I've got loads oh
I got this job as well so I was in his
TV show written by Abby Morgan called
Royal Wedding I think basically we
wanted to know if I could sing because
there was a karaoke scene in the show I
didn't really understand it was just
like come in and do the scenes then
maybe do a song so I learn the scene
around it which involves being heckled
so I'll start shouting at the room like
going like ah sure look like stop
heckling minute so I didn't pretending I
was getting the off lines that I've
learned and then I press play on the
iPod dock I'm pretended to be on stage
with the other actor who obviously
wasn't there and I sang this song and
really committed to it and as I turned
round at the end and sat down the light
right okay we just wanted to review
first time seeing yourself in costume as
the doctor so yes and we had numerous
costume fits and there was tweaks and
then the coat would be like this then
would get a difficult t-shirt and then
there was a moment when we knew it was
all right it was very much like the
scene in the episode whoever came out of
the dressing room and it was euphoric
because I knew this was a perfect
costume first Doctor Who episode you'd
recommend to someone who had never seen
it my first episode I mean I might be a
bit biased but
I have a really to not give you any
spoilers but I've got a really great
entrance into the into the scene that's
all you need and you get to know my
three best friends first job my first
job was I worked in the the local garden
center I was a pop washer very good very
good at pop washing first crazy fun
experience I've had a few I'd say one
that's really memorable that was
memorable I think for both of us was a
guy coming out of a tube station a young
lad and I thought he'd may be seen on
Twitter that was in the area because he
was in my full costume but he wasn't he
was just coming home from college and we
happened to kind of like I was like gee
what a picture it was I had I've not
come to find you I'm just like the
clothes so for both of us it was the
most amazing experience and he looked
incredible in my costume first memory
onset of Doctor Who guess what my first
day was yeah the crane so if you haven't
seen episode 1 of my first season I
jumped between two cranes and then have
a huge hero speech my first hero
speeches the doctor that was my first
day so it was very memorable because it
was windy it was a little bit scary high
up it was cold I was attached to wires
I mean baptism of fire first time seeing
the TARDIS I think they filmed around I
walked in and I was amazing he's quite
emotional because the first time I was
on a TARDIS it was Peters when I
regenerated so then when I saw my set
for the first time it was really
emotional because it was so different
but it was so it was so true to my
doctor so I loved it there you go
[Music]
you